(upbeat music)
- True or false.
The NCAA allows transgender
women to participate in
college sports as long as they
have been taking medication
that suppresses testosterone
for at least one year.
(upbeat music)
The answer is true.
The whole point of hormone therapy is
to help trans people match
their bodies with their mind.
So, if you're reducing
testosterone, your body
goes through the transition,
as well as your mind.
- True or false.
Federal law explicitly
bans discrimination against
transgender people in
housing and employment.
(upbeat music)
This one's false.
Though federal courts
do not specifically ban
this type of discrimination,
some courts are
interpreting discrimination
on the basis of sex
to include discrimination on
the basis of gender identity.
- True or false.
Legally changing your gender
invalidates your marriage.
(upbeat music)
The answer is false.
Changing your gender does
not invalidate your marriage.
The only way that it is
invalid is if you have
an annulment or a divorce.
Just because you choose
to change your expression
of gender, doesn't mean
you have to change your
love for one another.
- True or false.
A 2011 survey of 6,500
transgender and gender
nonconforming people found that 50%
experienced harassment by a co-worker.
(upbeat music)
That one's actually true.
When my birth name got out on my last job
I definitely heard about it.
True or false.
The North Carolina
bathroom policies are based
on previously reported
incidents of criminals
posing as transgender
and benefiting from laws
allowing transgender people to
use their bathroom of choice.
(upbeat music)
This one's false.
There have not yet been
any confirmed cases
of criminals attempting this.
Even though many states and schools
already have trans-friendly policies.
I'm not sure if Pat McCrory's done his
research on that one.
- True or false.
Over 200 cities and counties
have banned discrimination
based on gender identity.
(upbeat music)
I never thought I would
be able to say this
in my lifetime, but the answer is true.
Thanks to all of the allies
and people working hard
to change history, and to
make it safe for everyone.
We have been able to achieve this
in 200 cities and counties.
However, that's only 1% of the country.
We still have work to do
and we hope you stick
around to do it with us.
(upbeat music)